in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
[Music]
I'm here with dr. Ralph Hartmann he's
the medical director of the military
hospital in Berlin and the head of the
dermatology clinic thanks for inviting
me into your clinic if I've got a flu
this is caused by viruses and my immune
system usually can get rid of those
viruses and why is it that in cold sauce
caused by the herpes simplex virus this
is not the case that is because this
virus you have in your body and for
example when your immune system is not
working very well this virus takes its
chance to read up locate itself and then
you get what you can see here on that
picture so do you have any pills and
medication that can get rid of this
virus at all to be honest it's not
possible to get rid of this virus
because we only can stop this
republication
of other virus you cannot let's say kill
this so what's your best weapon against
it
we have virus statics since end of the
70s they came from Great Britain where
they very invented and that is a quite a
good thing that we have them because a
lot of viruses especially the superb
survives they can cause some really
strong disease many of my patients come
to my office with those kinds of cold
sores and they want to have some cream
to put on it and those creams may
contain virus static drugs so the wise
idea to do this well when my patient
asked me should I use them I would say
no it's not necessary because they are
cut they come too late you cannot stop
the virus from public ating because this
happens on an in another place when
patients say I but I have good
experience with it I keep the patient
okay then you can use it but actually
they don't work so they don't work
because the virus is not replicated
inside the skin because it's replicating
somewhere else in the body namely in the
nerve structures yeah and the cream is
not getting there
no it's not possible Nexus in so what
about herbal drugs like like home
remedies if you put this on them well
it's okay if you have good experience
with it if a patient says I'm fine with
it
leave the patients with that if I've got
a patient with this kind of cold sore
you don't really need to treat it at all
I mean it's itchy a little bit but it's
not dangerous but there are some cases
where you absolutely have to treat
herpes yeah that is the case when the
immune system of the patient is not
working very well when you have this
it's okay here you see a little bit more
and here all the lip is infected and you
can see here it's spreading around and
this patient already knows it when I
have this she's in danger of getting it
in the eye that's not so nice it's even
dangerous for your eye so it's inside
the eye Baalak yeah it's possible to get
from from the mouth to the eye and the
next patient she has a topic dermatitis
and the skin with patients with atopic
dermatitis cannot help itself good
against the herpes virus register there
she answered came from here and
spreading all over the body and those
patients they don't feel very well and
you have to admit them to the hospital
and what you do then you give pills we
treat this with virus statics and we are
very happy that we can do it because in
order to live and we didn't have them
you just could wait if the immune system
Vince all the virus wins and this means
the patient could even die yes that's
possible because the spreads to the
organs as well yeah and the herpes virus
of the whole group of this virus likes
the nerve system it's has an attraction
to the nerve system and even to your
brain so cold sores or herpes virus
infections are virus infections of the
skin which could spread to other organs
and there are different viral diseases
of the skin one of the most knowns our
shingles and this could be dangerous too
we just saw that the herpes zoster virus
is in many cases more serious than that
herpes
phlex virus and in many cases you even
have to treat your patients as
inpatients in the hospital so why is
that well when we see shingles on the
head or big areas of the skin are
affected or you have patients with a not
very good working immune system then we
take the patients inside our Hospital
and treat them here but what can you do
what a GP at the office can't well we
can escalate our possibilities to treat
it
give virus TEDx IV and treat the pain
that comes along with shingles so we
have more possibilities and we can
monitor all the patients when we have
them here and can you even alter the
disease the cause of the disease for
instance stop it from spreading well we
have to stop the virus from replicating
that what we can do and when the immune
system water of the patient is not
working Mariel we can give
in addition IV immune globulin to stop
it so how do you decide when you have to
admit the patient to the hospital we see
here a picture of shingles so is this a
case where you would like to treat them
inside the hospital
well when the patient is doing well it's
okay to treat it in your private
practice when the patient's not doing
that well you will send him here we will
see the patient for example our
emergency room and decide what we have
to do next and it depends yeah and
usually those things can spread yes here
we see a more or less normal skin
disease here was little R is equals and
when you see it here on the forehead and
close to the eye close to the nerve
system close to the brain in the end
this patient we would take in our
hospital and
right here are those vesicles the first
sign of shingles no a lot of patients
have pain long before we can see
something on the skin because the
replication of the virus happens in a
nerve node and it only comes when when
your immune system is not working good
enough to bring the virus down then it
comes to these vesicles on the skin
treating shingles is one thing
preventing them would be your more
general thing to do and there are some
vaccines outside right yeah we have them
since several years now there are even
ways to improve this shots they're
working on it and we would love to see
it because when we see what shingles can
do with patients especially with older
patients that with a bad immune system
and when they have this pain after
having other shingles so it would be a
good idea to help these patients with
vaccines and you should get even eyes in
Germany we advise the patients from the
year of 50 for example in Great Britain
is from 60s birthday that is a good idea
for getting the shot we got a view a
question from Mexico max leashed writes
that for the last six years he's had the
shingles on the left side of his face
and constant pain in this area what can
you do about this having this constant
pain that's the biggest problem
after having shingled purpose zoster we
see this in elderly patient and most
times on the head this patient needs to
see a pain specialist and they should do
whatever they can and for example when
we treat the patients right here in the
hospital we ask our patients please not
be brave tell us when you have pain so
that we can give you painkillers because
on the other hand input get get trying
their pain system keeps this pain even
when the virus is not working anymore
then this note is ruined and giving the
pain signal to the brain dr. Pam thanks
so much for inviting me today into your
clinic
[Music]
you